hey
today's question comes from caleb in uh
iowa he says i'm 23
making 120 000 gross and so far i've
been able to
earn my way out of the dumb financial
decisions i have made
without really changing my lifestyle and
i've struggled following a written
budget
i've been at baby step 4 without really
ever really changing
my lifestyle on more than one occasion
but
always end up relapsing down to steps
two and three
in the next few weeks i will once again
pay off the non-mortgage debt
i have and have my three months
emergency
fund any tips on getting on board with a
more responsible lifestyle
at this step so i can quit this
cycle 23 23
uh you are the problem um
and i think the and i say that in a
respectful way caleb
i think you you're asking us for advice
i think you need to look in the mirror
and tell yourself it's time for
discipline
and intentionality okay there's no
reason why you should be going back and
forth you don't have nothing major
happening in your life it sounds like
you're just making
poor decisions and i always teach this
to 23 year olds dave that the caliber of
your future will be determined by the
choice
you make today and he's not making the
right choices that's true of a 53 year
old too
so caleb i think you're halfway there
by recognizing the problem
uh when you don't recognize that there's
a problem then you don't
have to address it my dad used to say
knowing that there's a problem is ninety
percent solving it
yeah a lot of people are just unaware
that there's even a problem they're in
the zombie apocalypse and just wandering
around right
and just in a zone and uh so i think
you're halfway there just by
recognizing that there's an issue and
uh what happens
is as we go through our life we have
different things that come into our life
that call us to a higher level of
nobility
uh for instance when you get married you
have your first child
suddenly you will do anything to protect
and provide for that child it uh it
takes someone who was self-centered and
they grow up almost instantaneously
you know they they become other centered
that little baby
other centered you know and that's one
time that it happens
other times you can just uh
it's a matter of like where you are
caleb it's just a decision
uh like for sometimes i run into people
your age caleb that
aren't married don't have a kid but
they're looking at a different kind of a
why you need a big why is what we're
talking about a
reason to not lapse yeah
and that baby is an example of a reason
to not lapse
but another one that i was talking to
anthony you and i believe we're talking
to the young man
he's a strong faith oh yeah and his
reason for
that was he he didn't want to disappoint
god he wanted to be a faithful servant
yes
he want to be trustworthy worthy of
trust
yeah before so it was a thing between
him and jesus
it was not a it wasn't a it wasn't i
don't want to let dave down or anthony
down
it wasn't my wife's gonna be mad at me
it wasn't my kid can't eat because i'm
misbehaving
it was i just don't wanna let jesus down
i want i want to be worthy
of trust i want to be a good steward a
good manager of god's resources he
as an act of his faith he became his why
yes
yes and so i don't care what your why is
but right now you just don't have one
yeah yeah
and um you know you need a real reason
i'll give an example okay
somebody who wants to lose weight to to
look nicer in their clothes
is not nearly as motivated as someone
that the doctor says
if you don't lose 50 pounds and get your
cholesterol down you are going to
die yep i have a different why
fitting in your clothes versus dying
okay it's a different kind of a why yeah
it raises you to a different level of
motivation it does and the interesting
thing is
that you can just decide that item is
there
now you don't have to decide you're
going to die i don't mean that but you
can have you can
just go i'm just disgusted with myself
and i'm not going to do this anymore
yeah you know that's a decision
and he's kind of heading towards that
this verbiage is
getting increasingly frustrated with the
guy in his mirror you see it yes i see
it
i mean here's the thing or two i want to
say caleb dave
is talking about a why and one of the
things i talk about on my channel is
if your why doesn't make you cry then
the price of commitment
will make you cry you need to dig very
deep into yourself and find something
that just
activates that emotional side of you as
a young man what can make you care
deeply yes yes and when you can identify
that then you will never go back to what
you're saying you do not want to go back
to
i ca i could never go back to sleeping
in the back of my car i can never go
back to
living paycheck to paycheck i can never
do that because
what i care about so deeply on the
inside
just gets me so emotional that it it
pushes me forward
even when i feel like something and it's
how people break major stuff like
addictions
yes they have to have a why yeah yeah
they have to have something that's
better than the drink
yep they have to have something that's
better than the drug
they have to have something that's
better than the porn or the gambling
it's a it's more important to them
than that item is and and you've got to
care deeply
and so you could take those kinds of
ideas folks
and uh
just by putting some thought to it some
prayer to it some meditation to it
and in a sense you are manufacturing
your nobility your why
and the beautiful thing about caleb's
situation is he's asking
the question yes most people in our
culture are so oblivious that they need
to even
ask that question and even if someone
asks it of them they become offended